I've recently developed a nasty
case of hitting the phobia,
generally suffer from
anxiety surrounding sleep.
It's become a significant
negative force in my life,
cause unknown,
I'm rather well put together and
successful across many domains.
Any advice?
Yes,
go to bed later.
So one of the things that happens to
people when they're having a hard time
going to sleep and their sleep is
disrupted is that they tend to go to bed
earlier to catch up on their sleep.
And that actually has
a counter that's cut,
that works at counter purposes to
what they're trying to attempt.
What you want to do is delay your
sleep until you're really quite tired.
So stay up much later.
Get up at the same time in the morning,
but move your sleep time later,
maybe half an hour night until
you actually do fall asleep.
Um,
the other thing that you could look into
is that there are relaxation exercises.
Behavior therapist offered those,
but I'm sure you could find one
online at a breathing exercise.
And so often what you do is imagine
you're laying in your bed and you're
nervous.
And so what you do is you concentrate
on your feet and you flex your toes and
then breathe in and out and relax them.
And then you flex your ankles
or their soles of your feet and,
and breathe in and out and relax and do
that with every muscle group all the way
up your body and remember to breathe
deeply and regularly and that can help
regulate your anxiety.
So I would say stay up later
till you're clearly tired.
Um,
the other thing you might try
is sleeping in a different room.
Um,
and then the final thing is there are
pretty effective sleep medications like
Zap laplant for example,
which is seems to be pretty effective.
And if you're really having
a hard time sleeping,
maybe you could try something like
that and see if it and see if it helps.
You don't have to try it forever.
But,
so the simplest thing to do though is
to go to bed later and because you'll be
more tired and more likely
to fall asleep then.
And it's really not going
to cause you any trouble,
so that's what I recommend.
Okay.